hey 42 here imagine
you're on holiday in a little town on
the french riviera
you've had a long lazy day of
sightseeing
sunbathing and sampling tasty food
the sky is blue the sun is warm the
water is sparkling
and you just feel about on top of the
world
and the best way to finish up such a
glorious day
a slap up meal in a local restaurant of
course
where you order delicious freshly caught
sea bream
perhaps wash down with a glass of wine
before wandering back to your hotel for
a
long peaceful sleep except what if that
bream
turned out to be harboring something
rather unexpected
for one 40 year old man holidaying in
france back in 1994
it did he started feeling a bit nauseous
about two hours after his dinner
and probably thought he had food
poisoning not great
but it happens the next day things got
worse
with vomiting blurred vision and muscle
weakness
realizing he wasn't in a good way he
figured
it was time to end his holiday early and
drive home
but it quickly became clear that wasn't
going to be an option
because surrounding him inside his car
was a cloud of giant screaming insects
after doing a bit of screaming himself
he ended up in hospital
where he spent 36 hours before being
released with a clean bill of health
so what had happened was it something
he'd eaten
well yes it turns out that
seabream he consumed wasn't any old fish
but a particular species called sarpa
salpa
just so happens to be hallucinogenic
in arabic this species of seabream is
known
as the fish that makes dreams because it
causes vivid
sometimes terrifying hallucinations
in those who eat it but not everyone who
eats hallucinogenic sarpasalpa
does it by accident hearing of this
mysterious fish
back in 1960 a national geographic
photographer
named joe robert set out to deliberately
trip on seabream a chef cooked it up for
him with stewed pumpkin
he ate it up and reclined in his seat to
await
fishy bliss perhaps because he knew what
was coming
he had a much more pleasant experience
roberts reported seeing a new kind of
car that was steered with a stick
like a plane now i come to think of it
maybe elon musk has been eating some
sarbasalpa
and then he found himself taking
pictures of a monument
marking man's first trip into space
robert said afterwards it was pure
science fiction
and he isn't alone the tradition of
getting high on fish
goes back thousands of years some
researchers suspect
romans got off their tits on sea bream
whenever they got the chance
and it's certainly plausible sarpa salpa
is
found throughout the mediterranean and
east atlantic
so it was definitely swimming in roman
seas
which at the height of the roman empire
was basically
all of the seas also the romans weren't
exactly shy
when it came to intoxicants the average
daily wine consumption
in the roman empire is thought to have
stood at around a bottle a day
per person and it was drunk by everyone
including slaves and children they
along with the greeks were also rather
fond of opium
using it both as a painkiller and a
pleasant sedative
it wasn't at all unusual for romans to
drink opium based
cretic wine to help them sleep at night
and
opium was freely available for market
stalls across rome
the opium poppy seed also features
heavily in greek and roman mythology
in homer's odyssey helen of troy spikes
some wine with a drug that
took away painful memories and the bite
of pain and anger
reading between the lines most
historians think this was opium
one roman emperor marcus aurelius was
even known to be
a full-blown opium addict so the romans
were no strangers to
mind-altering substances where they all
sat around eating fish to get high
it's fun to imagine and it's certainly
possible
but it's probably more likely that they
accidentally stumbled into
sarpasalpa-induced
trips just like the men in the french
riviera
at the beginning of our video you see
it's actually kind of hard to
deliberately trip
out on sarpasalpa because not every
specimen you find in the seas
causes hallucinations if they did
perhaps they'd be illegal
and there'd be a roaring black market
trade in seabreem
of course it's quite the opposite it's
commonly sold in restaurants and markets
around the mediterranean and beyond
but exactly how a sea breem becomes
hallucinogenic
is still a matter of some debate though
scientists have some interesting ideas
the primary one being that the
hallucinogenic properties
derive from phytoplankton that live on
seagrass
and make up a significant part of the
fish's diet
this particular algae causes
hallucinogenic toxins
to sit inside the fish's organs which
if the levels are high enough can cause
tripping amongst
unsuspecting fish eaters we know there
are more reports of hallucinations
after eating sarpas halper during the
spring and summer
when phytoplankton blooms peak as the
sunlight penetrates the murky water
and encourages growth we also know
you're more likely to end up tripping
after eating sarpasalpa
if you eat its head as that's where the
hallucinogenic toxins are most likely to
accumulate
so perhaps if more people ate fish heads
there would be more folk walking around
having
conversations with invisible flying
penguins we don't actually know
what toxins cause these hallucinations
but our best
guess is it's a chemical called dmt
which just so happens to be the active
ingredient in ayahuasca
a psychoactive brew used in ancient
shamanic rituals
and dmt just so happens to grow on
algae if you're thinking of carrying out
your own
research not that i suggest you do
you'll know asapa salpa by its
distinctive gold stripes
whilst it's usually found in warmer
waters
the occasional lonely specimen is known
to make its way further north
in 2009 a cornish fisherman named andy
giles caught one
telling the daily telegraph now i
realize what it was and the effects it
can have
perhaps i should have taken it into town
two cells are some clubbers
but sarpa salpa isn't the only
hallucinogenic fish in the sea
there's even a name for the effects that
they cause when eaten
which looks like this and instead of
trying to pronounce that
i'm just going to refer to it as
tripping one's balls off
over in hawaii there's the nightmare
vekay
a hallucinogenic goat fish legend has it
that pahalu the god of nightmares was
killed by an enemy with a stone to the
back of the head
causing him to fall into the sea where
his spirits jumped into a veke fish
which apparently explains why you'll
have nightmarish visions
if you eat one today as well as
hallucinations eating nightmare veke
can cause sweating tingling and
tightness of the chest
as with sarpasalpa it's thought that the
nightmare veke
gets its hallucinogenic properties from
the algae that it eats
and again it's suspected that eating the
head
is the main culprit in reality eating
hallucinogenic fish
is relatively safe with no long-lasting
ill effects
still i wouldn't recommend it however
sarpasalpa
and the nightmare vekay pale in
comparison to other sea life
that can cause a condition known as
ciguatera poisoning
which not only gives you hallucinations
but causes food poisoning symptoms like
vomiting and diarrhea but it also causes
numbness vertigo hypertension
heart problems and the most delightful
item on
every list of symptoms death cycloterror
sufferers are commonly misdiagnosed
with multiple sclerosis before it's
eventually linked to
a dodgy fish dinner though the symptoms
usually subside after a few weeks
some people never recover and are
permanently disabled
even for those who do recover a relapse
can happen
years down the line and it can even be
sexually transmitted
that's right you can get a fishy disease
even if you've never eaten fish
in your entire life you can usually
contract this disease
from fish from tropical or subtropical
reefs
including many that you'll see on plenty
of beach restaurant menus like
sea bass snapper and perch like other
toxic fish it's caused by their diet
not algae this time but the
single-celled organism
gambia discus toxicus but if you manage
to get through life and avoid death by
seabreem or snapper there's always
the poison poison tasty fish the
notorious fugu
one bite of the wrong part of this
puffer fish will sends the potent
neurotoxin
tetrodotoxin rushing through your veins
which paralyzes you causing you to stop
breathing
and die there is no known antidote
delightful and yet people actually eat
this stuff
but whilst pufferfish may be deadly to
humans
one particular marine creature uses them
to get off its fishy tits a film crew
following a dolphin pod
in 2013 was surprised to find the
dolphins playing with a puffer fish
encouraging it to release its toxic
chemicals in self-defense
then rather than being scared off the
dolphins lapped up the neurotoxin
and subsequently entered a drugged up
trance-like state
during which they spend hours seemingly
mesmerized by their own reflections in
the water
the oceans are full of hazardous fish
and whilst i certainly wouldn't
recommend
emulating the dolphins and scouring the
waters for
little spiky balloons of death if you do
happen to tuck into a piece of sea bream
on a mediterranean beach
and start to feel funny strap yourself
in
for an interesting couple of days thanks
for watching
check out my new podcast random
interesting facts
available on youtube spotify apple
podcast
and anywhere else you get your podcasts
link in the description below
thanks